تقسيم روسيا هو ما تسعى اليه الدول
الغربيه بحسب الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين الذي برر وفي تصريح غير متوقع انه
هجومه على اوكرانيا كان يرمي الى توحيد
الشعب الروسي ان كل شيء يستند الى
السياسيين الذين يهدفون الى تقسيم روسيا
روسيا تاريخيه لقد حاولوا دائما القيامه
بذلك يحاولون القيام بذلك الان لكن هدفنا
مختلف تماما توحيد الشعب الروسي
لكن بوتين الذي يدافع عن وحده روسيا كما
يقول نجد مجددا بموقف كياب وحلفائها
الغربيين الذين يرفضون اجراء محادثات وعبر
عن استعداده للتفاوض لايجاد حل مقبول
للصراع عرض شككت في مصداقيته الدول
الغربيه ورفضه الرئيس الاوكراني طالما ان
بوتين هو رئيس روسيا يقول زلانسكي الذي
تعاهد باستعاده جميع المناطق الاوكرانيه
التي ضمتها روسيا
العام يجب ان ندرك ان عدونا سيحاول يجعل
هذه اللحظه مظلمه وصعبه لقد خسرت روسيا كل
ما يمكن ان تخسره هذا العام لكنها تحاول
تعود خسائرها بالتباهي والدعايه بعد
الهجامات الصاروخيه على بلدنا والبنيه
التحتيه للطاقه
في الاثنى تتواصل ضربات الروسيه على مدينه
خيرسون الواقعه في جنوب اوكرانيا التي جرى
تحريرها في الحادي عشر من تشرين الثاني
نوفمبر من سيطره القوه الروسيه كما
تتواصلوا المعارك بضروره في مدن اخرى مثل
خاركيفو ميكو لايف